no
bene
ottimo video con questa
nello scorso video in cui ha scelto il
nome vi ho detto sta questa vita
raggiungere il saggio mila mi piace fare
un altro video con la piccolina e il 7
mila mi piace li ha raggiunti subito
ecco anche tappeti na rota lasciate un
mi piace su questo video se al sestetto
video raggiunge rispetto e mila mi piace
faremo un altro video con la gattina
eccola qua che video faremo oggi abbiamo
comprato alla piccolina e ai giochi più
strani per gatto che abbiamo trovato
online e ora li proveremo a tre perle e
vedremo quali di questi giochi le piace
di più sembra che per ora le piaccia di
più rosicchiare il mio dito ma insomma
non è questo uno dei giochi ed è anche
voi nei commenti scriveteci alla fine
del gioco che vi è piaciuto più di tutti
proveremo quattro giochi anzi se volete
fate un voto da 1 10 ogni gioco
iniziamo subito con il primo gioco i
piccolina sipro per scoprire i nuovi
cecchini per te
[Musica]
sembra una tigre in miniatura anni i
commenti ci avete chiesto in tanti vado
via berlino dove è finito berlino non vi
preoccupate ora merlino sta dormendo giu
nel di vado si sta che dorme sul divano
ci stiamo facendo conoscere il piano
piano un passo alla volta
così il piano piano si abitueranno e
speriamo che diventeranno amici dunque
stiamo firmando il video anche di come
si stanno conoscendo piano piano che
uscirà fra qualche giorno quindi
attivate la campanella per non perdermi
la reazione berlino ma ora iniziamo
proprio il primo gioco il primo gioco e
questo topino in cui si ri qua
e fibre come gira e
guarda un po
poi il giochino nuovo guarda
non sembra molto interessato a lui gli
piace tanto ma forse dobbiamo metterlo a
terra e farvi vedere che si muovesse
interessatasi non interessa molto questo
giochino
ma insomma se in piazza ottobre si
ricorre i topi
è
confusa piccolina allora questo aiuto
pino e tu sei un gatto lo so che questa
topino è grande quanto tempo per mettere
scatti porto e un gatto a cui non
interessano i topi
mi sa che il primo giochino è proprio un
flop
eh sì se non interessa per niente e
aspettare forse le ps se si muove così
si è visto come sta andando a prenderlo
vediamo lo sta studiando
si è iniziato a giocarci forse l'inter
essa
sembra più interessata al cerchietto che
c'è nella coda perché forse far rumore
viviano
ha proprio carino
e dvd carinissima aspetta che lo nuovo
così forse ti piace di più
come ha usato queste topino armi lo
sgambetto
compresi stufino del cerchietto lo stava
portando in giro cosa
si guarda guarda piccolina quindi
un po indecisa e ha deciso di mangiare
la coda che ora sembra che le piazze di
più il giochino profilo ei voli
staccarle la coda è ma che fai
vuole staccare qualcos'alto pino
mele cola
[Risate]
ecco sto giocando
che no non mi dire che si è già rotto
non solo fuori quella cosa non sono o no
eccola
correndo fino in meta dormita c'è un
topino lì e ti stai dormendo e che sta
prendendo il tubino
proviamo sfruttarlo vediamo
ok io direi che lei come voto a questo
topino leda borse un grey e mezzo perché
non è super
entusiasta sta mangiando
ora ci stai giocando di più forse ora le
piazze quindi forse
anche io gli do un 7 a questo giochino
allora pensavo fosse un 6 però vedendo
la tua gara adesso forse arriva anche ad
un obolo sarebbe 8 perché io voto citate
il primate se non nei commenti passiamo
ora il prossimo giochino
[Musica]
prossimo giochino da sembra una normale
pallina
ma a un campanello e una piuma takata
antimafia si muove j basta accendere
questo pulsante
ci sono varie modalità proviamo
innanzitutto con questa è la piccoli
mezzo arrivata eccola qua si preferisce
giocare con i lacci delle mie carte ei
guerra questo giochino
la più mattina
si è incastrato
sta scappando
beni rubati tutti tengono sotto
ricorrendo e un po compiuto ma com'è
possibile che questa cosa si muove da
sola
[Risate]
quindi no
non è più puri invece
un piccolina
se ne è ancora sicura
ma dove il catino pallina o no
incastrato
eccolo qua
presta a essersi bridge
ok proviamo a cambiare modalità
ancora in testa dalla pallina
tirava
[Musica]
forse vuole prima ispezionarla senza che
si muova vediamo e che voleva solo
adorarla
proprio lasciargliela così dispensa
chamber vediamo se gioca
[Musica]
e quindi mi interessa
andiamo ad accenderla adesso
[Risate]
l'uomo a metterla sul tappeto vediamo
come si cammina anche sul tappeto
vediamo
un cammino però sembra che lei piace di
più camp è forse perché fa meno rumore
e forse le piace di più sul tappeto
qui c'è anche il fatto che cambia i
colori quindi forse lattina di più
[Risate]
ei piccola quindi che ne pensi di questo
giochino è troppo grande per te oggi
piace
[Musica]
prendere la pallina
beh propone la se la pallina
carina
come vuoto secondo me ci vorrebbe dare
un 5 da questa pallina almeno all'inizio
ma adesso le piace di più anche merita
un bel 7 7 e mezzo forza perché è più
interessata
bene piccolina che voto dai a questo
giochino allora vengo dove la piccolina
le da un set perché forse ancora troppo
grave questo giochino che per le vie di
piccolissima voi che voto gli date
scrivetelo nei commenti possiamo ora il
prossimo giochino
terzo giochino
guardasse che carino è un topino con le
piume qua che si muove un pochettino
cade così poi qua si possono anche
inserire delle crocchette che cadono in
base a come si muove vediamo prima come
resiste lo piccolina
ma è più interessata a mangiare i
pantaloni ma insomma c'è un giochino il
nuovo guarda
e il giochino quando ti sei accorta
se n'è accorta vediamo come reagisce
sembra che le piacciono molto le piume
o che priva la messa catene piazza molto
questo giochino
soprattutto per le piume che sta
cercando di mangiare
distruttrice
proviamo ora mentre
quello preso tappeto
ecco come si muove
granocchiaio tutte le piume
che carino sembra che si stia divertendo
un sacco
e perché io voglio stare nessun
obiettivo morbide non voglio spostarsi
dagli
piccola
preferisce il mio dito al gioco insomma
il giochino qua
li volete un prezzo non chi era il fiume
mano favole alfino
vogliono sempre sgranocchiare
ha catturato alla piccolina che voto dai
a questo gioco
98 e mezzo di
donne piace io invece do un 8 questo
giochino perché le piace molto giocare
con una cosa però non lo insegue forse
appunto perché è un po grande per lei
che piccolissima voi che voto di date
scrivetelo nei commenti che stiamo ora
l'ultimo giochino ultimo gioco questo
gioco e super trono speriamo che le
piaccia anche se un po grande per lei
che ancora piccolina però il super
divertente
pesce
il soffitto si muove anche ma prima
facciamoglielo vedere senza muoverlo e
vediamo come reagisce bolivia si che
l'acqua è piccola e guarda un po un
paese
[Musica]
a controllare che cos'è
ma questo è un pesce vero per mamma
primo paese vero un anno ma l'odore del
pesce
controlliamo meglio
sta tutto il mutato perché le reti
l'odore di pesce e potete il dado e
facendo un agguato al pesce
vuole mangiare il pesce è
perché piazza volta questo con la
mansarda l'ho abbracciato
dal cercato di mangiarlo
che carina si è trasformata in una tigre
ta non si stacca più guardate come lo
avventa
e l'integrità
si sta divertendo sax
quartet e le piace un sacco questo gioco
che carina proviamo adesso ad accenderlo
e vediamo come reagisce eccola qua e nel
frattempo assalteranno clan dei miei
pantaloni va beh
eccolo acceso
non fosse vero come reagiranno invidiamo
ei ma
lei perché ti sei fermato
mi ha un po scioccata
ehi ma che sta succedendo
magiaro tutto
sembra molto interessato tutta
divertendo
[Musica]
allora vi sta ripassando
la festa
si
10 no
ora continuerà a giocare il business le
spiagge caldissimo io direi che lei dato
[Musica]
e ora la scelta finale
ora per la prova finale per scoprire
quale le è piaciuto più di tutti
metteremo tutti i quattro i giochini a
terra e vedremo da quale giochino va per
prima o con quale preferisce giocare
proprio posizioniamo i giochi prima il
topino poi la pallina
poi l'altro topino
e poi il peso vivo
ora la mente un partner rivediamo dopo
lo zucchino fa
la
quale scenderà
si sta pensando
no
chao
e dove sei andato è però quando chi
viene dopo
quei siti merda
[Musica]
non ci posso credere
nel frattempo questo fa
male se gli piccola
forse certo quello con la piuma
[Musica]
ari controllando tutti e sta vivendo
[Applauso]
credo proprio che lei abbia scelto
invece mi piace io c'ero e
quindi ha vinto il
passato poi mi piace se volete una
seconda parte che compriamo altri
quattro nuovi giochi la settembre mi
disse se questo video sintesi mila mi
piace fare una seconda parte ora fine
sono aperte linee sacrificare prima dei
nostri altri miei occhi calcio quella
che preferite buona visione